[Applause]
[Music]
after 9/11 the world of aviation changed
forever nowadays things seem to be about
change once again
[Music]
in this era of globalization where
everything is becoming increasingly
connected who hasn't been on a plane the
fact that flying is relatively common in
most countries of the world these days
is kind of an extraordinary feat it's
actually much more extraordinary than
you could imagine don't believe this
well check out the following data in the
middle of the 20th century in 1950 31
million passengers travelled the world
by air back then flying was a luxury
that only a few people could afford by
1986 that number had increased to 960
million passengers pretty incredible
right what if I told you that last year
in 2018 a whopping four point four
billion passengers were transported by
air on 38 million flights
American Airlines alone the largest
airline in the world transported almost
200 million people in its 6,500 daily
flights in 2018 it's crazy
[Music]
Aviation is so essential today that one
couldn't imagine a world without it now
times change and aviation has also
changed and some of the questions we can
consider these how are the airlines
business models changing the how will
this sector evolve in the future and how
will that affect us well listen up
different models for different times
traditionally folks the big airlines of
the world concentrated their operations
in one or very few airports from these
bases they offered long all destinations
that way passengers coming from domestic
flights cooled feeders spent transit
time in these airports before then
traveling abroad often wasting a lot of
time at the airport I'm sure you've
experienced this annoyance this model is
known as hub-and-spoke though we will
call it the central hub model
[Music]
this model based on giant airports has
made sense for many years why well
because it facilitated long-haul routes
which were operated with huge airplanes
airplanes that needed to transport many
passengers to be profitable these were
called dense routes Airlines needed
passengers to come from different
origins and converge in the hub so that
they could later put them all together
on a single flight to take them to their
final destination it's pretty logical
[Music]
and not only that the sector was also
affected by huge regulations for example
in the United States all routes between
states were considered to be of public
utility and in most cases the government
itself was in charge of setting prices
programming frequencies and even
proposing or rejecting new routes so
every time an airline wanted to open a
new route it had to get the state's
approval sometimes years would pass
before they managed to approve new
routes and they often let too long legal
battles
but folks all this changed up once with
the airlines deregulation law which was
approved in 1978 this law introduced
free competition and gave airlines a lot
of reiden to operate based on their own
market criteria it was precisely this
change within a very short time that led
to a new business model that Southwest
Airlines managed to exploit to the
fullest and that was the birth of the
low-cost model
in contrast air industry deregulation
arrived in Europe much later competition
between Airlines it wasn't allowed until
1993 nonetheless it saw such huge
success that in just four years by 1997
the entire process was completed
nowadays markets in the United States
and Europe quite difference perhaps due
to their evolutions in the United States
the variety of destinations the numbers
of users and above all the weight of
their regional routes make it the
largest air market on the planet
[Music]
low cost companies such as Southwest or
JetBlue offer a huge variety of
point-to-point destinations that is the
passenger travels from their origin to
their destination without having to stop
at an intermediate airport and you know
what I can already tell you that this
model is the future in Europe on the
other hand though they are moving out
with huge strides the sector is still
less developed than in the United States
as many small airlines coexist in
addition Regional Transport isn't so
important largely thanks to the
excellent railway connections the
Achilles heel of the United States and
that's another topic we certainly have
to talk about here on visual politics
some day but not today but folks the big
question is where is the future of
aviation going
well everything indicates that the
market is inclined to offer more and
more direct routes that is routes
without stopping the major airports and
this explains news headlines like this
a380 Airbus to stop making super jumbo
as orders dry up you see the fact is
that thanks to the evolution of
airplanes which are much more efficient
and cheaper than before longer flights
can be operated by smaller airplanes at
a lower price this is called a thin
route and it is shaping the future of
aviation we're talking about a huge
paradigm shift here under this concept
the big airport hubs of the world could
suffer a great deal
[Music]
and that's not all let's consider the
two largest aeronautical manufacturers
in the world
Boeing and Airbus have taken the race to
lead the new revolution in the sector
very seriously for example a few years
ago the American Boeing released the
Boeing 787 which promised an efficiency
never seen before in aviation that was
until the Airbus a350 arrived a
groundbreaking aircraft combination of
the best European technology the
lightest and most sustainable materials
and the most efficient engines on the
market in this battle to leave the new
aviation revolution competition is
fierce so fierce in fact that some
companies are having to make great
efforts to adapt to the new times
Emirates and the end of the a380 who has
in terms of Emirates and it's gigantic
a380 with luxury suites showers and
on-board shops we're talking about one
of the most luxurious and reputable
airlines in the world here but the
company based in Dubai is about to
launch the biggest change in its history
see Emirates is the most radical example
of the over-exploitation of the old
traditional hub centered model virtually
all of its passengers pass through Dubai
either as their final destination or to
make a stopover on one of its 3,600
weekly flights to 138 destinations
around the world in addition every one
of its aircrafts is huge its fleet was
based solely on the Boeing triple7 and
110 mammoth Airbus a380s the largest
passenger plane in the world in fact
Emirates has the largest fleet of this
model on the planet and actually without
Emirates as a customer the a380 program
would simply be unsustainable the future
of the Airbus a380 on the line as
Emirates considers a 350 switch if a
significant portion of the Emirates
orders cancelled we believe the a380
program must end
sandy Morris analyst at Jefferies
International this may be the clearest
sign that the aviation sector is
beginning to undergo a revolution think
about it for a minute the fact that
Emirates itself owned by the emirate of
Dubai is thinking about no longer
relying exclusively on do buyers a hub
pretty significance equally significant
is the decisions you no longer continue
to acquire the a380 the company's
flagship airline Emirates rethinks its
network for a world without the a380 we
haven't been growing at the pace we used
to because of geopolitical issues in the
region and elsewhere but that's given us
time to take stock of what the network
is going to look like in five to ten
years and what fleet will fit in that
Network and the type of aircraft that
it's going to be tim clark president of
emirates
[Music]
by the way another question we could ask
ourselves is how would this paradigm
shift affect Dubai a city that as you
know isn't enjoying the best of times
right now
the thing is that airplanes like the
Boeing triple7 X the a330 neo into the
a350 have become the new stars of the
market these three new models boast much
more efficient performance which allows
them to operate on less dense routes
with a greater profit margin thus this
makes the hub's obsolete of course
changing times brings the most
opportunities for new competitors in
this game there are companies doing
things differently and that is allowing
them to have huge success so listen up
[Music]
airasia
the success of the low-cost hybrid one
of the greatest examples of recent
success has its origins in none other
than Malaysia AirAsia is a low-cost
company with more than 250 aircrafts and
it transported almost 45 million
passengers in 2018 it's hybrid strategy
a mix of both the central hub and
point-to-point model has made it the
continents largest low-cost airline in
just over 20 years their secret a model
based on low-cost subsidiaries in which
each subsidiary has several operations
centers these are sort of like micro
hubs or small domestic hubs that way
AirAsia manages to take advantage of the
high-density population and the huge
number of tourist areas that exist in
this part of the world now with its
affiliate AirAsia X its new big bet it's
trying to go a step further you see
AirAsia X is its long distance
subsidiary its objective to operate
long-haul flights from these domestic
hubs
thanks to new aircraft such as the a330
near this company we'll be able to offer
attractive prices without needing a
large passenger demand in Europe perhaps
the closest thing to this model is
Norwegian of course on the old continent
we have our own way of doing things and
we have a world-renowned company that is
often talked about that has forever
transforms the European aviation market
Ryanair the democratization of air
transport in Europe
can you imagine Europe without the
possibility of escaping for a weekend to
visit the city you dreamed of when you
were a child well today it seems hard to
believe but that was Europe not so long
ago the low-cost airline model that was
born from the deregulation of the
aviation market hasn't only changed the
industry but also the lives of all
Europeans we've already talked about
this here previously on visual politic
Ryanair began its journey in 1985 with
25 workers and a single 15 seat plane
flying the route between Waterford
southeast Ireland and London Gatwick now
the company has grown into a giant with
more than 400 aircraft that fly to 225
destinations in 35 countries and that is
certainly no small achievement their
success looking at Southwest and
importing the low-cost model to Europe
for the very first time the model that
is based on sacrificing services in
exchange for paying less and flying from
origin to destination in a single flight
that is from point to point
thanks to this millions of people who
previously couldn't travel within Europe
now do so frequently on this or another
of the many low-cost European companies
that have sprung up in the last decade
or so this has definitely been a huge
advantage in European integration even
traditional companies have had to adapt
to compete creating reduced rates with
fewer services in Europe this model has
grown exponentially in 2018 more than
500 million low-cost seats were offered
which is a historic record and although
it many anticipated the ends of
traditional aviation the truth is that
the opposite is actually happens there
has been a democratization of the
markets because the prices of the big
flag companies have drops to be able to
compete in a changing market annoucer
accessible to many more people
but the question is can all these
changes completely eliminate the
centralized large hub model well that is
gonna be really complicated even though
the traditional hub model is no longer
as important as it used to be then dis
likely to decline the big traditional
companies have enormous structures that
are linked to this model which they
won't be able to change easily right now
it seems unfeasible to think that the
point-to-point model will impose itself
on long-haul flight routes in the short
and medium term but of course that
doesn't mean that many airlines and many
large hubs such as Dubai won't start
having problems in fact there are many
indications that they will hear a visual
politic we're going to be keeping an eye
on all of these changes so I really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast who provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always I'll see you next
time
[Music]